foreign
thousands of protesters in Tel Aviv
demonstrating against prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's plan to change
Israel's judicial system
on the surface the atmosphere is almost
festive
but the concerns are hard to miss and
I'm thinking especially about my
children and my grandson
Netanyahu insists his proposed changes
will strengthen democracy but these
demonstrators don't believe him
with many now worried that the most
right-wing government in Israel's
history may also attempt to limit their
freedoms I'm afraid that my way of life
as a non-religious person as a
technologist as a woman and a leader is
going to be very much in danger we see
the economy deteriorating
then there are the concerns about the
military
thousands of army reservists had
threatened to stay home if the
contentious judicial Bill became law
which It ultimately did
senior military leaders sounded alarms
about the impact that could have on the
military's combat preparedness
is a veteran of the Israeli Army and a
member of the veterans protest Movement
we never assume
we actually need to stand up against
major forces within our own government
many In This Crowd say What's Happening
Now is unprecedented as turmoil and
uncertainty grow the deepening political
crisis here is only exacerbating social
divisions Israel is now more polarized
than ever before mayor elrond is a
senior researcher with the institute for
National Security studies he's also
concerned but says he remains optimistic
a solution can be found the problem is
that right now we do not have this is a
really you know issue we don't have
really the necessary mechanisms
of a dialogue
between the sides but we have to
establish some kind of rules of games
how to manage and enhance this kind of a
dialogue but with talks between prime
minister netanyahu's Coalition and the
opposition at a complete standstill
compromise and consensus seem farther
away than ever before
Tel Aviv
foreign